The Joe Rogan Experience dude I was 350
pounds
I believe you said it best I saw the one
with you and Louie and Joe and you were
like Bobby ate himself into a shape
but when I first met you you were young
and thin and good looking I was gorgeous
but I remember I've met you twice that
was so funny too it was such a perfect
description
um I met you at UFC 100 and you came out
of the back you went you you looked at
me and go what happened to you
I was like I was like Hey Joe how you
doing no it's been it's it's been an
addiction for me since I was a kid it
was my first addiction when I was a kid
was food it was a you know I remember
when my ma I had an abusive stepdad for
a while five years and uh I had nobody
and I remember I found food like I would
wake up in the morning
and uh say goodbye to my mom in sixth
grade go out the front door go around
the back crawl into the basement and in
the corner of the basement I had a
little pillow and a blanket and I would
just sit there all day and I would eat
so you'd pretend you were going to
school I pretend I was going to school
because I was just so afraid I had no
friends I had nobody and I was in a
major depression and I didn't know it
and I would sleep in the basement and I
remember I would just eat
food like you know Susie cues and ring
dings and it just made me feel almost
like a friend you know
um
you know I just had a problem and I I
remember I got real big and then uh
my six day my sixth grade teacher
actually Mr de percio got me into
running it was like all of a sudden I he
became my dad
you know he kind of took me under his
wing and we were at the Olympics
remember the the sixth grade Olympics
and it was just horseshit thing but I
remember to do the 440 all the way
around the track
and then maybe come up and goes Kelly
you gotta win I want you to win
and I remember I was like I win now
[ __ ] I just I just wanted somebody to
[ __ ] believe in me you know what I
mean yeah and I remember I was racing
against this skinny black kid as fast as
Lightning and I remember we were running
and I [ __ ] won I remember I beat him
everything I had and I won and I just
felt fantastic I started jogging I
started doing marathons wow uh but you
know then I got into drugs after that I
found drugs and uh very shortly after
that in seventh grade and then I of
course went to you know jail went to go
to I think I went to jail the first time
13. Jesus um yeah that was terrible what
did you go to jail for oh I'm robbery
assault and battery and malicious
destruction trespassing and breaking
mobation holy [ __ ] so breaking probation
at 13. I was on probation I was on
probation at 12. oh my God so what
um I I robbed a canteen truck
of cigarettes and [ __ ] I think
Twinkies wow
um so I got on probation for that and
then yeah it was terrible the first I
remember that we went to jail at 13.
yeah my uh my bail was I think 10 bucks
and my mother didn't pay it
because the the judge said she said what
do I do and she she was like uh let him
go through the system
let him go
and my mother listened to him oh my God
yeah it was bad because I remember I was
in the jail cell Somerville Courthouse
the jail cells downstairs the regular
prisoners and the Juve stay downstairs
so I had my own jail cell and I remember
I was looking at it like pay the [ __ ]
money because all my friends moms paid
and they got out they got out and I went
they take you downstairs
and uh she came down and I just I walked
up to her and I was just crying and she
was like Bobby she's crying I'm so sorry
I you know blah blah and I just turned
around and started doing push-ups
and uh then they came and got me and
they throw you in the van the regular
prisoners would be in the back of the
van and the juvies are in the front
behind the drivers on a bench and I just
remember the real prison is just hey
little [ __ ] you know just I was
[ __ ] my pants and they take you up
to Danvers State Hospital uh Danvers
State gave there's a the morgue they
gave to the detention the you the
juvenile detention so you go up there
it's called intake and you get up there
and there's a bunch of other kids they
strip search you and you got to get
naked and do jumping jacks I'm 13. you
gotta bend over it was embarrassing it
was terrible you go into this room and
there's all these other kids of all
nationalities just in this room watching
this one TV
remember they came in with a box of deli
sandwiches
and chocolate milk and everybody ran
over and grabbed and you grab a sandwich
and they they had these purple onions on
top these wet onions because I think
they were old sandwiches that they would
donate to the juvies and they all took
them and threw it on the ceiling and I
looked up on the ceilings it was just
years of onions [ __ ]
terrifying and then the kid comes up
he's like hey man when they call you out
ask them where you're going
uh and if they don't tell you it's
somewhere bad if they tell you it's
somewhere good so like Cali I went out
they started shackling me and they
handcuff me and I'm like where am I
going and he just looked at me and he
shook his head
and uh they Shackled me to two other 18
year olds I was 13 and they took me to
the Charlestown y
so the Charlestown y the bottom floor
was the Y but the top floor was a
juvenile lockup
so you had to go through the gym go
upstairs and they take into this room
and they again I got strip searched I
had to get naked you go and then you
have to take a shower I was 13 I had a
little pecker I think I had like you
know four pubes and I'm showering with
these 18 year olds next to me it was I
was scared [ __ ] that night they uh some
kid got a pencil in his eye from another
kid
and uh and then you go into this room
with just bunk beds
steel bunk beds filled in the room and
the highway I don't remember the
Charlestown y the highway with 93 was
right there so it's just cars like as
close as me and you were just whipping
by on the highway all night long and uh
yeah I went to jail and they from there
you just go to another jail another jail
for I think it was until I was 15 I was
going in and out of juvie jails and
Foster homes Jesus Christ for uh for
because once you're in you're in so if
your mom had just paid that 10 bucks you
would have never been I'd probably be
dead really I'd probably be in jail jail
real jail that saved me and you know
there's that thing where it's like that
I don't know if you've heard that thing
where you know you don't know is is it
good or bad I don't know yet you don't
know if something's good or bad yet you
got to wait you know you think
something's terrible right
but you don't know it could be good you
just don't know yet it feels like [ __ ]
and it felt like [ __ ] but if she didn't
do that I wouldn't have got sober I got
sober at 15.
I went to a place called the road back I
got arrested again Upstate New York they
shipped me back to Boston because I was
a a ward of the state you're owned by
Massachusetts
so they shipped me back down I went back
to jail and then I finally realized like
look
drugs and alcohol that's what it's not
people places and things it's my
drinking it's my drugs I go I need to go
somewhere what drugs everything I did
everything anything you put in front of
me I wasn't doing drugs because I like
drugs I was doing drugs because I didn't
want to be alone anymore I didn't want
to go back to that basement by myself
you know what I mean yeah I didn't want
to be that anymore that was terrifying
to me so
if I had to do drugs or I had a drink
I would do whatever the [ __ ] it took to
have friends
you know to have a group of people to
belong because I didn't have anybody so
these kids you know I got to the point
where I would move around like I'd get
out of the jail I'd go to a foster home
and then I would go home from there and
my parents were somewhere else like they
were in Spencerport uh New York they
were in uh Bensalem Pennsylvania and I
what I would do is I'd go on the first
day of school and I would get into
trouble go to detention because those
are my kids so I get in trouble go to
detention and I'd always have weed
I'd always have a couple joints and as
soon as I got to detention I'd lean over
to the toughest looking kid I'd be like
you want to smoke some weed
friends immediate friends yeah sure we'd
smoke weed and those are my guys and and
then I'd hang up with them for the
duration until and Ben Salem I wound up
running away and getting arrested again
and then in uh what was it Spencerport
New York was the last time I got drunk
we [ __ ] stole gumball machines
I went to jail for gumball machines it
was stupid
um it's terrible because you know I mean
I we got I drank a half a bottle of
Scotch
I drank a bunch of beers and I we did
whippets
and they were like I want these gumbo
machines so I just took them and smashed
them and the cops came I remember I was
running from the cops down the railroad
tracks I hopped the fence and as soon as
I hopped the fence it was a shotgun
right in my face
and the guy made me get down the cop
he's like freeze get down the ground and
goes if he moves shoot him
and I was like it was gum oh my God they
took me to jail up there and it was that
was the worst yelling Rochester New York
was the worst show I've ever been in and
uh you know they put me in a room and
that was the first time I literally
asked for help
I was just like help me
please just help me I'm done
I know I know it's drugs I know it's
alcohol please help me get help I need
it
um whatever I just gave up I gave up the
first time I was like this is it and uh
then I went to jail to Boston they flew
me on a plane remember I was smoking on
the plane wow I asked the flight
attendant can you give me a light she
just got me a light I lit up in the
[ __ ] place you could smoke on smoke
I'm playing I was 15.
and um right when I got off the plane
there was two state troopers waiting for
me and they handcuffed me took me to
jail and then I met uh
I met this guy in NFI shelter care was
this uh Yitzhak his name is Yitzhak he
developed this system
for juveniles
that it was called open door setting
normalization
um there was no locks on the doors
identify there was no you know guards
really they had people there at night
but you could run
you could leave walk right out the
[ __ ] door
but they incentivized you 30 days you
got steak 60 days without a run lobster
dinners
they incentive they gave you
responsibility as a kid and they we all
kind of form together to kind of keep
each other in check to to receive these
benefits and they gave you you know help
you know they they talked to you instead
of these other places just went into did
your time this place was all on you we
had school we could go we went they took
us to the beach they loaded us and I
remember they took all these juvies we'd
load up in a van and go to Gloucester or
wingashik Peach and we just sit on the
beach and have fun they gave you these
incentivized things to not leave
and then the guy came up to me he's like
you can go to a rehab we got you set up
you can go to six months co-ed or you
can go to a year on boys
and that was I was like what do I do
he's like knowing you you're all boys if
you go with his girls you'll [ __ ] up
you'll [ __ ] up you'll try to bang the
chicks you'll try to have sex and you'll
[ __ ] it up so I did I listened I was
like okay and I went to the road back
it was a house again normalization no
bars no nothing I showed up and I was
sitting in this room this guy Tom
Tompkins used to be uh had a lot of
money his wife was a famous opera singer
he was in Show Business
and he lost it all from alcoholism and
drugs so he started this house called
the road back
and uh
I remember I was sitting there petrified
and uh all of a sudden
he comes down there's all the staff and
there's this one kid [ __ ] being [ __ ]
this place I don't want to [ __ ] be
here [ __ ] this I want the [ __ ] out
screaming and yelling and he came down
the stairs old dude Gray beard psoriasis
he had a misty cigarette you know those
little Slim and Sassy
just smoking it he came down he goes
where's this [ __ ] [ __ ] up where's
this [ __ ] sucker that wants to leave
because like me he's like you want to
[ __ ] leave you want to get the [ __ ]
out of here get the [ __ ] out there's the
door you [ __ ] [ __ ] and one of the
councils the new counselors was like hey
maybe we should he goes [ __ ] you you're
fired get the [ __ ] out
he goes you want to go [ __ ] leave
there's the [ __ ] door okay I'm trying
to save your life you little [ __ ] head
I'm trying to save your life if you want
to [ __ ] live stay here and shut the
[ __ ] up if you want to leave get the
[ __ ] out but I care about you and I
don't want you to [ __ ] die
and the kids start crying and he's like
yeah okay are you staying or leaving
because I'm gonna stay he goes great I'm
glad you're staying because you're gonna
you're gonna save your life now and then
he goes where's Kelly I'm like right
here and he goes meet me upstairs
and I went upstairs
the sweetest human being I've ever met I
mean he was that he just
saved my life this guy was the best
person I've ever met in my life he
he used to take us to his house to build
entertainment systems
and he would [ __ ] give us Elio's
pizzas
and little cakes and [ __ ] I thought he
was trying to [ __ ] me you know I mean
you know what I mean because every once
in a while these kids would just take
off in the van oh my God he's like Kelly
come on let's go my guy I gotta [ __ ]
suck this guy's dick now [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
gonna to blow this old guy in his house
for cakes and pizza
you know I mean
but he didn't he was just [ __ ] wanted
us to get better